cry guy
all right are you active hey you're at
the bomb station I'm at the bomb station
all right I will I will read you what's
going down at the bottom station you
need to follow my instructions carefully
if you're gonna make it out of there
laughs I have the instructions in front
of me cry okay all right there are four
there's a force symbol button thing
there's four symbols and four buttons
okay okay I'm looking at the keypads all
right what can I do Jay all right
there's a three with an antenna and a
tail there is AC with a dot in the
middle nananana nananana calm the [ __ ]
down all right what the [ __ ] are you
talking to man okay okay wait there's
there's a see there's a pen oh my god
damn there's to see with it dot in it ya
seen the dog yeah there's a lowercase B
with a T in the yeah yeah got it got it
got it and there's a backwards P yeah
what do we do with it you say there's
four symbols yeah wait what way would be
P rosam dildos there was stuff right
what wait you were just reading them off
again you weren't actually telling me
which ones [ __ ] okay talking it back cry
you're gonna die oh my god we go with
strength we got a hurry all right there
is e oh my god did you think I was gonna
oh my god I'm sorry
cry you might kill yourself okay okay
all right
okay okay okay I got okay okay okay okay
okay okay
uh-huh okay press the C Percy took dust2
triggers this - we're down it's going
fast it's two and a half minutes left
no kinda snotty the C was not it feels
not it on the top okay so press the P
first
I died are you serious yeah I'm dead
that is the worst round of this game
that I have ever experienced
we should probably edit that out I feel
so unintelligent right now
holy [ __ ] now let's go ready reset reset
reset let's go here we go okay how are
you ready
yes okay okay so ready I'm so hot I got
all my chambers here see the bomb yeah
okay you see the bump I didn't go
yeah to go okay behind oh my dick okay
there is there is four buttons yep on
the bottom of it and there in the top
there's a screen that has a number there
oh wait wait wait let me find it alright
okay they said there's a there's a four
buttons at the bottom and the top screen
above it and then get the right okay
this is the subject of memory let me
just read what a [ __ ] it does I should
have done this before
I'm sorry hearing [ __ ] I skipped class
in bombed school up press correct but it
to correct Nick leg to pee all stages
pressing an incorrect but it will reset
running out of time okay what is the
display saying for wait a second okay we
have four minutes I am going to die if
you don't
okay press the bottom in the fourth
position alright the button in the
fourth position is a one we need to
remember this uh already down done okay
right then okay pregnant now
now it says a one hmm can do I'm so
stressed out you can do this believe
agreed just get it done press the button
labeled four okay that is in the fourth
position press the button with the same
label as you press in stage 4 which was
the previous one that was a one right
yes
we got it okay [ __ ] yeah you're gonna
live cry over so smart okay what's next
yep okay I gotta stop with snus okay
good that alarm went off it you don't
like us okay
the next two were put the same type of
things they're their buttons okay
they're giant buttons giant buttons and
love giant buttons okay what am I
looking at I need some direction I
there's so many [ __ ] papers
you gotta yell you gotta use your inside
voice come on use your inside [ __ ] are
you talking about Christ scream for me
ah it is a blue button that says press
on it you have 1 minute and 40 seconds
nothing about a blue [ __ ] but good
come on okay okay don't worry I got a
putt be run I can't
we have no movement keys in this game
I'm holding the button down it's a blue
stripe please tell me you have some kind
of knowledge but relieves when the
countdown timer has for in any position
all right the next one is a red detonate
life jackets what's do
please there's so many papers 15 seconds
up my trip press twice yes are you
serious I don't know what happened I
lived but I don't know what happened oh
you just said something right now
there's nothing about pricing twice are
you [ __ ] kidding me are you ki are
you serious your lip yeah that's [ __ ]
awesome intuition if you're an idiot
just go with it 9 I don't feel any pride
or whatever but we get it there's no
sense of satisfaction oh all right
that was some multiplayer action with
cry it's huge
oh [ __ ] if you enjoyed this video leave
a like and as always stay awesome Chris
yeah very easy Dean we're gonna girl
space it's like oh like what she's
looking at but it's a phase of ovaries
exploding some people can't handle the
beauty penis but I still kind of like
want to hit play